[Music]  [Music]  i will break you  i promise  [Music]  are you in trouble  i need my birth certificate  i need you to help me  i'm going to be a marine  marine  no you ace gayer than two left shoes and  everybody can see  or injured in this it  including several american servicemen  who were on patrol there this all i have  left  of the dream i held for you  question is  why do you want to be here i want to be  a marine  that's not good enough to be a good  marine means to know thyself and seek  self-improvement that means you give it  they kicked you out didn't they  my mom  she won't even talk to me  most of my friends are dead or in jail  if i die in this uniform  i'm a hero  somebody  who can't be supposed to break you down  wanna go home  relieve  they  because it's the thing that protects the  marine to my left and to my right sir  i could have left you at any doorstep  i am never  giving up on us  you